es momento de economía en este el último
día de septiembre y por ello recibo con
muchísimo gusto daniela blandón ramírez
la especialista de económica de daniela
el desempleo en américa latina' muestra
recuperación con excepción de brasil sí
señor alan muy buenas noches pues la
organización internacional del trabajo
estima que unos 34 millones de personas
en la región han perdido su empleo por
cuenta de la pandemia en algunos países
la situación ya comienza a mejorar según
dicen las cifras como por ejemplo en
colombia la tasa de desempleo en agosto
fue del 16 8% por supuesto mucho más
alta que el año anterior sin embargo es
mejor que el 20,2 por ciento de julio en
chile la porción de desocupados bajó
hasta el 12 9% en el trimestre que va de
junio a agosto también paco bajó un poco
frente al trimestre móvil anterior pero
sigue estando en los niveles más altos
en una década brasil es el único de este
grupo que reportó sus cifras hoy y que
por el contrario marcó un récord su
desempleo fue del 13,8 por ciento en
julio
aunque también se conoció que en agosto
creo casi 250.000 empleos al año también
hablemos de argentina y es que la
pobreza está afectando a 4 de cada 10
argentinos si pues la oficina de
estadísticas de este país reveló hoy que
el índice de pobreza se trepó al 49% en
el primer semestre y llegó a niveles de
hace 15 años esto quiere decir que la
pobreza afecta a 11 7 millones de
ciudadanos y que la tasa ha venido
creciendo desde 2017 cuando era del 26%
como vemos en el gráfico en apenas un
año ya iban 32 % y ya pasa el 40%
también es mayor a lo que era hace un
año como consecuencia de la pandemia
pues uno de los datos que más llaman la
atención alan es que entre más jóvenes
son más pobres el 50 y 63 por ciento de
los menores de 14 años vive en la
pobreza y también casi la mitad de los
jóvenes de entre 15 y 29 años y si
observamos el índice de indigencia osea
los ingresos que no alcanzan para cubrir
una canasta
básica de alimentos los afectados son el
10 5% de la población estos son unos 83
millones también hablemos de venezuela
daniela y es que las autoridades de este
país preparan herramientas jurídicas
para defenderse de eeuu bueno el
presidente nicolás maduro no dio
detalles de qué herramientas
específicamente va a usar sin embargo
presentó la que llamó propuesta de ley
anti bloqueo ante la asamblea
constituyente que como sabemos es
controlada por el oficialismo con esta
ley el mandatario dice que busca burlar
los mecanismos de persecución y bloqueo
internacional que aprovecho para hacer
un recuento de lo que denuncia han sido
los efectos de las sanciones de la casa
blanca
en seis años
perdimos el 99 por ciento del volumen de
ingreso en divisas
dicho de otra manera de cada 100 dólares
o euros que el país obtenía por venta de
petróleo en 2014 hoy o tiene menos de 12
europa con temas relacionados al break
city es que el reino unido firmó un
acuerdo de pesca con noruega bueno está
a punto de culminar una semana decisiva
para el acuerdo comercial post exit que
deberían firmar el reino unido y la
unión europea pues mientras los
representantes de londres y bruselas
están sentados en la mesa noruega
anunció hoy que logró un acuerdo
bilateral de pesca con el gobierno de
boris johnson este país sabemos no
pertenece al bloque comunitario pero sí
al mercado único y por eso tenían que
definir cómo va a ser ese intercambio
mutuo de cuotas de pesca y el acceso a
las aguas de cada país justamente esos
puntos son los que han complicado las
conversaciones en bruselas porque no es
lo mismo negociar con uno que negociar
con 27 alan vamos con los indicadores
económicos de este miércoles en wall
street del cerro en positivo pero
despidió un primer mes con pérdidas
desde marzo justo hoy se confirma una
contracción del pib
1 en el segundo trimestre en eeuu las
bolsas europeas con excepción de madrid
bajaron después de que se conocieran
malos datos en reino unido y en américa
latina' un buen repunte en la bolsa de
buenos aires en donde pronto llegará una
misión del fondo monetario internacional
y vámonos con la cifra del día con que
cerramos septiembre y por supuesto con
mafalda a propósito de la muerte de su
creador kino pues bastaron nueve años de
publicaciones para que ganara en
numerosos premios entre ellos el
príncipe de asturias de comunicación y
humanidades tuvo 20 millones de
ejemplares vendidos sólo en argentina
sus libros fueron traducidos a más de 30
idiomas hablen pues con este emotivo
adiós
daniela muchas gracias por este
recorrido económico y ustedes gracias
por su compañía sigue en francés 24